this is a strand beast that's Dutch for
beach animal my name is theo jansen I'm
a kinetic sculptor and I try to make new
forms of life on beaches these
structures are made of PVC tubing shards
are skeletons which are able to walk on
wind power
so this animals are : are not depending
on foods they eat the wind - the same
several of Johnson's creations are
currently on display at the
Exploratorium in San Francisco where you
can actually interact with some of these
things one on one so what you see here
in the Exploratorium are all extinct
animals but we are able to reanimate an
extinct animal by pumping up the wind
stomach with a compressor and then the
animal comes alive again for a few
minutes in the museum just like in
Jurassic Park the why question I don't
know why I make this animal sister I
don't do it by intuition like you ask
parents why do you make children it's a
question which you don't really answer I
mean you just do it the strand beasts
are on display at the Exploratorium now
through September 5th it's the third and
final stop on their first major tour of
the Americas so don't miss your chance
to interact with these unusual creatures